[Music]
[Music]
on april 23
2020 i uploaded my very first zelda
related video on this channel which
means that we have recently surpassed
the one year mark though the channel has
existed for longer than that i honestly
don't even remember what i was using it
for prior to that maybe for smash
brothers replays or music playlists i
really don't know i've been doing
corporate animations for a number of
years and my quote-unquote youtube
career kicked off when i was brought on
board as an editor for the commonwealth
realm where i had been editing zelda
videos on a weekly basis for
around 8 months or so then as kovit made
its presence known around the world a
lot of corporate projects got delayed or
outright cancelled
and i was suddenly left with a lot more
free time than usual
instead of just hanging back and waiting
for new jobs to eventually return
i figured this would be a great
opportunity to do something i've been
wanting to do for a while
starting my own youtube channel since
then the channel has grown at a rate
which
exceeded my wildest expectations i
sometimes come across comments who say
my channel is underrated or that i need
more subs and
that is honestly very heartwarming to
read but at the same time
60k subscribers in one year doesn't feel
underrated to me
in fact it is more than i would ever
think was possible in such a short time
especially since i didn't really have
like a plan or business strategy for my
channel
i just wanted to make zelda videos and
so i did and here we are today
still making zelda videos on a weekly
basis with the same passion as when i
started
since my very first video was all about
dungeons it seems fitting to celebrate
this anniversary with another dungeon
video
but not just any dungeon video your
dungeon video for this special occasion
i've asked you the viewers to submit
your unique ideas for a future zelda
dungeon
now there were a lot of submissions way
more than i expected and i was
pleasantly surprised by the creativity
and imagination you guys have
unfortunately i had to narrow it down to
a reasonable number i would have loved
to include every single one of your
ideas but
that would stretch this video beyond my
limit i did manage to include more
people into the video
since there were quite a lot of
overlapping and complementary ideas
as such i decided to combine some of
these concepts together into one general
dungeon idea
if i somehow overlooked your idea or you
had a similar idea but you weren't
included i apologize
there was a lot to go over and even
though i feel like i've read every
single one of them
it's always possible that some manage to
slip through i also want to reiterate
that if your idea didn't make it in
please don't take it personal i
appreciate each and every one of you
equally and there's always a next time
one last thing to mention is that for
this list i've been working together
with an amazing artist
who is none other than ganondoodles
they've been doing some great work for
other creators in the past and for this
video they've been kind
enough to help realize some of your
ideas by creating concept art so i hope
you enjoy that little extra touch
but let's not delay any further here are
25
dungeon concepts brought forth by the
zelda community
[Music]
so far the zelda series has included
dungeons based on a lot of different
architectural styles but never before
have we explored one based solely on
feudal japan the closest we've gotten
was the yiga clan hideout
though i'm hard pressed to call this a
dungeon thus the idea of a japanese
style house or mansion is
very alluring david bernard aiden
cogswell and the teacher all weighed in
on this idea
david suggests a japanese house deep
inside a forest with sliding doors
secret rooms godzillas and ghost type
enemies the best comparison i can think
of in recent times would be
shogun studios in paper mario the
origami king an imposing
asian style castle filled with these
types of sliding doors secrets and booby
traps david is referring to but of
course in the style of zelda instead
aiden coxwell says this could be a shika
dungeon but not like the ancient
technology themed ones akin to the
shrines and the divine beasts but more
so based on the modern day chica we
encounter in kakariko village which are
heavily based on japanese culture
both in terms of their architecture as
well as their fashion the teacher also
thinks it's about high time we get
another
dungeon based on a mansion a bit like
snow peak ruins from twilight princess
and most importantly bring back the soup
asian soup this time
as for a possible boss idea david's got
you covered he suggests that the boss of
the dungeon would be the owner of the
house
a woman dressed in a kimono who appears
friendly at first but ends up
transforming into a monster at the end
the idea of the boss appearing as a
normal friendly entity at first
is of course very reminiscent of jetta
who comes off as sweet and innocent at
first and then
ends up transforming into blizzetta due
to the influence of the mirror of
twilight
next on the list we have a dungeon in
the form of a town or village
very fitting with the recent release of
resident evil village
instead of an enclosed indoor space as
is normally the case with zelda dungeons
this town or village would be out in the
open of course
the closest we've come to this idea in
the 3d games was probably the city in
the sky
though to be honest even though it has
the word city in its name
it doesn't really feel like it what we
would be looking at here is a real
proper town with many houses and other
types of buildings to explore
adam carmay jeffrey time agent y camille
and rinse miguels all sketch a similar
idea
a secluded town with a mystery attached
to it as such a dungeon like this would
be more focused on one giant puzzle to
figure out perhaps as jeffrey states the
town could be
haunted or cursed and link has to find
the source of this mystery by solving
puzzles and basically playing detective
this whole endeavor could then lead up
to a boss fight on the town square or
something like that the closest we've
come to something like this would be the
village of the blue maiden stage in four
swords adventures which is about solving
a mystery
surrounding the villagers being spirited
away by an unknown force but i think
this idea could be expanded upon and
translated into a 3d environment
it would definitely make for a unique
dungeon experience
if there is one thing that brings true
tension to a video game
it is an enemy that is so strong and
dangerous that fighting it head-on would
be a death sentence
and misled chip soso chan and axacon all
seem to dig this concept we've seen this
idea used in other games in the past
like resident evil's mr x
the evil within silent hill 2 and more
recently half-life alex in the infamous
chapter named
jeff an enemy who is so powerful and
dangerous that running and hiding is the
only way to go until you find a way to
defeat the monstrosity once and for all
some may shiver at the thought of this
concept as it can be
very stressful but i personally love
this idea because it creates a
relationship between the player and the
boss
instead of just a random monster who
pops up at the very end as his tradition
with the zelda series the entire dungeon
is the boss fight in a sense this would
also be a great way to have the main
dungeon item hidden away at the very end
of the dungeon and one which finally
makes it possible to defeat the boss
who's been stalking you mercilessly up
to that point
we've only gotten a small taste of this
idea in a zelda game like the wall
master who keeps following you from room
to room trying to take back the orb link
is trying to steal
this part generally gave me anxiety at
the time if only for the ominous music
and the feeling of being chased
constantly
however link is never actually in danger
himself there's also the central chamber
on lomme labyrinth island in breath of
the wild here a guardian stalker patrols
the area and if you were still in the
early stages of the game that is to say
a small health bar and weak armor like i
had when i first visited here this
mechanized giant can give you quite the
spook as it creeps around the corners of
these hallways
now imagine that but with better ai and
scripted encounters and you got yourself
one
tense dungeon experience
[Music]
this one kinda speaks for itself a
dungeon shaped like a giant tower for
some reason there were quite a lot of
suggestions which all mentioned
a clock tower specifically think tick
tock clock from mario 64 but
in a zelda game i've talked about a
tower dungeon before in my first two
videos and even modeled one as a
demonstration
but whereas mine was just an abstract
construction with little rhyme or reason
it would of course be more interesting
if there was an actual theme to it like
a clock tower as mig
jay and throck durloy suggested joan
cruz suggested something similar
but in this case it's a rideau tower
with wind as its main theme and mechanic
shadowgill proposes that each floor
could have a different element or its
own unique enemies michelle mentions a
dragon atop the tower acting as the
final boss which would be a great
callback to twilight princess and ashton
describes a huge cylinder shape tower of
which its floors can be rotated whether
it's a clock tower an
ancient rito tower or a more abstract
giant cylinder the idea of descending
upwards further and further until you
reach dazzling heights has always been
very appealing to me
especially since the punishment of
falling down can be unforgiving and with
breath the wild's open air design
philosophy
climbing and paragliding this can turn
into an absolute banger of a dungeon
dimension shifting is nothing new to the
zelda franchise
we've been doing it since all the way
back in a link to the past but this has
usually been reserved for the overworld
and not inside an actual dungeon in a
link to the past using the magic mirror
inside the dungeon
simply sends you back to the entrance we
have seen the games toying around with
the idea of traversing the dungeon in
two different time periods like in
oracle of ages and of course more
famously the sand chip in skyward sword
but aside from some small changes in the
aesthetics of the dungeon
it was still just the same place just in
a different state of time
some doors would be accessible in one
and blocked in another or a certain
device or switch would only work in one
or the other troubadouring do wants to
take it a step further
instead of simple time travel this
dungeon idea would incorporate different
mirrored worlds we can shift between
these parallel dimensions would have a
lot more differences than just some
visual changes it would be cool to see
two vastly different worlds but which
are still connected and where one can
still affect the other
think of the normal world and the nether
in minecraft as an example
both could have completely different
enemies atmospheres and puzzles to solve
the first thing that came to my mind
while reading this idea was silent hill
origins where the player can use mirrors
to transport themselves between two
different dimensions
a light world and a dark nightmare world
though here the two worlds are still
pretty similar speaking of mirrors abby
normal complements this concept and
presents the idea of a medusa-type boss
who would be made vulnerable by
utilizing mirrors to expose its
weaknesses
zelda dungeons have historically been
tied to all sorts of different elements
from forest to fire ice and water the
list goes on
but what if we had one dungeon that
centers around different biomes as
kalakai melee suggests
a culmination of many different elements
and weather types kind of like the first
stage of ganon's tower in ocarina of
time but taken to the extreme
we've also seen this concept used in the
trial of the sword to a certain extent
where rooms had different elements and
even different weather in some cases
like rain lightning and snow
but that wasn't really a dungeon it was
completely linear and centered around
combat alone
imagine if you built an entire dungeon
around these biomes not just combat but
puzzles mini bosses and even a final
boss as well
say you need to melt ice in one area by
bringing something hot like a smoldering
rock from another or carry ice or water
back to a desert area to solve a puzzle
there
legend beast and kolwan simons add to
this idea by proposing a mechanic which
allows us to shift between seasons or
different weather types again
something we've already seen in oracle
seasons but only in the overworld and
never inside an actual dungeon
playing around with elements is cool and
could provide some amazing puzzles this
whole
idea of different biomes also makes me
think back to luigi's mansion 3 where
each floor of the hotel was a unique
environment
and in some cases with different
climates as well
[Music]
a dungeon which in and of itself lies in
a different dimension is
always welcome in my book we've seen
this with the palace of twilight in
twilight princess
and to a very small extent the spirit
realm in skyward sword but in skyward
sword these were just small fetch quests
with a slightly more foggy glowing
version of the overworld and not an
actual dungeon so to speak
and in the case of the palace of
twilight this is a place which link
actually physically
visits by traveling through the twilight
portal however ibos presents the idea of
link instead
astroprojecting himself into another
world while his actual body stays behind
a bit similar to how link's spirit was
trapped inside the sacred realm in
ocarina of time and
well speaking of the sacred realm anna
loves crafts ruber kofab124
obi's mongies and titanfall 64 all came
up with the similar idea of a dungeon
inside the sacred realm more
specifically the temple of light
the temple of light was built by the
light sage raaru to hide the triforce
but as far as we know the triforce has
not resided in the sacred realm ever
since ocarina of time and the
traditional six sages haven't been seen
since twilight princess
perhaps the temple could have been
tainted or corrupted since then
we never actually see much of the temple
of light other than the chamber of sages
a surreal dream-like room link would
visit each time he cleared one of
ocarina's temples it would be amazing to
see more of the temple of light
and the idea of link visiting this place
in spirit form rather than his physical
body would also present all sorts of new
ideas for puzzles and themes
since as we saw in breath of the wild
spirits seem to abide by slightly
different rules of physics they can
float and manifest and such so i
definitely see some cool possibilities
[Music]
if you're familiar with the lore of
skyward sword you know that the master
sword
is not just an object used to kill
ganondorf there are in fact two
different entities who house themselves
inside the legendary blade that being
link's former companion phi
and the source of reincarnating evil the
demon king demise
now we don't know for sure if this cycle
will ever be broken
some suggest that since ganondorf will
likely play a key role in breath dwell 2
perhaps now is the time to finally break
the cycle once and for all whether or
not this will actually be the case
remains to be seen
but if there's one way to do it what
would be more awesome than a dungeon
inside the master sword an idea which
isaac utsi
and annie stone suggested if this would
be the case this would likely be the
final dungeon of the game
instead of the typical ganon's lair or
ganon's tower we would have to travel
inside the sword itself to face demise
and break his curse
a dungeon like this could be themed
after the conflict of light and dark
since
phi and demise both represent the
opposite of the spectrum it would also
be cool to see phi in the flesh again
as long as she shuts up about the
batteries in my joy-cons
okay so imagine the hyrule castle
section from twilight princess you know
the part where wolf link is being held
prisoner after having been taken away by
one of the shadow beasts
now imagine that but instead of breaking
free just like that and being on your
way
link is imprisoned and has to slowly
find his way out and face whoever put
him there in the first place this is the
idea that johnny peacock ravio the
triforce films and daniel lahaye all
propose
prison break zelda i love me some prison
escape movies
and the idea of playing this out in the
form of a zelda dungeon
count me in since he's a prisoner it
goes without saying that he would have
been stripped of all of his equipment
and weapons which is a great way of
having him start from scratch within the
confines of a dungeon environment
it's also a great callback to the
forsaken fortress where link is left
vulnerable without a sword and has to
sneak his way across for the majority of
the time spent there
there are no video game-esque puzzles
and perhaps not even a dungeon item
the entire goal would revolve around
getting your equipment back and finding
a way to escape
like the forsaken fortress a dungeon
like this would be centered all around
stealth and evasion at first
until you find your stuff so you can
fight back
aquatic freshness lioness mapping and
mass majora all seem to have a profound
love for
flying cities and while we have seen
something like this in the form of the
city in the sky
this one is a callback to what is in my
opinion the best location in skyward
sword that being
skyloft god only knows what happened to
skyloft after the events of skyward
sword we never see this place again and
if we are to believe the story of the
game the ones who used to live there
settled down on the surface and never
returned there's plenty of theories
about it
some make the argument that the city in
the sky is skyloft
others tie it to the palace of winds and
minish cap but none of this has ever
been proven without a doubt
if skyloft was abandoned for millennia
it would be amazing to revisit it after
all this time in the form of a dungeon
in a way it's a bit similar to the
dungeon town idea but i still had to
include it because
come on it's skyloft the origin point of
the zelda chronology
remember how in metal gear solid 4 you
could go back to shadow moses after 4
games and it's in a state of complete
decay
something like that a nostalgic trip
back to an old location
now this is a very interesting one by
timothy odd
in a way it sounds similar to the idea
of link projecting himself outside of
his body
like we talked about in the sacred realm
dungeon but there's a catch
these projections of link are in two
dimensions rather than three and
i'm not talking about the wall merging
from a link between worlds
as cool as that mechanic was it was
pretty limited in what you could do with
it
a better comparison would be the 8-bit
sections from mario odyssey where you
can actually jump
attack and have full range of motion in
two dimensions timothy also mentions
that this dungeon could be tied to the
shika technology where link scans
himself into a machine and is then
projected into a 2d environment
these sections could serve as puzzles to
open doors for instance
finishing a 2d challenge would then
allow you to advance further into the
dungeon whether this is a side scroller
like mario odyssey or zelda 2 or top
down i will leave up to you to decide
but hey
nintendo already made a 2d prototype of
breath the wild during development so
maybe a good way to put that to use
[Music]
libraries are inherently mysterious all
the knowledge kept in these places the
smell of old books the silence so what
would be more amazing than a huge
abandoned ancient library to explore
that is exactly what paper sonic sir
nicholas and noah thurson propose
paper sonic makes the comparison to the
10th episode fittingly titled
the library from one of my favorite
series of all time
avatar the last airbender here hang and
his friends stumble across an enormous
ancient
largely abandoned library in the middle
of the desert sir nicholas describes a
hogwarts-esque environment with moving
staircases
wiz ropes flying book enemies and a
miniboss in the form of an old man
or creature on a sliding bookshelf
ladder who bombards link with books
very creative in my book pun intended
noah 2 describes an old rundown library
filled with darkness cobwebs and
monsters though in this case they make a
connection to lo rule and
even suggest that we play as ravio
instead of link a great idea if we ever
get a spin-off of a link between worlds
and lastly i also wanted to include an
idea from yaibini
thousand who wants to see a dungeon that
revolves around reading an ancient
language perhaps
zonai or some other forgotten language
and well what better location to do
something like that than
in an ancient library furthermore they
also make the suggestion that the main
item of the dungeon would be something
akin to the book of madura and i love
that idea
after all not every dungeon item has to
be a weapon or an item that gives you
more mobility a mysterious book which
you can use to decipher ancient texts
both in the dungeon itself and in later
parts of the game is also very
satisfying the last time we saw
something like this in a zelda game was
the ancient sky book in twilight
princess
which was criminally underused something
more close to the book of medora from a
link to the past would be amazing as
here it was used multiple times
throughout the adventure
in a way the divine beasts already took
some light inspiration from steampunk
but zelda has never gone all the way
with this
and while i'm conflicted whether or not
zelda should go full steampunk someday
we could at least start with a dungeon
in this popular style
10 000 subscribers with one video great
name by the way
refers to stovepipe island which was an
unused island concept from the wind
waker that never made it into the final
game
they pitched the idea of a steam-powered
robot boss which can be defeated by
destroying pipes
and ultimately the dungeon experience
results in an escape sequence where the
dungeon floods with water
jon pro too likes the idea of a
steampunk inspired zelda dungeon
and refers to an amazing piece of fan
art made by dave song and while again
i'm not sure about
ganondorf being the central figure in
this i do like the idea of a rich
maniacal host who stands in the way of
link and possibly zelda as well
they also bring up the idea of a steam
train where you fight from wagon to
wagon kinda like a gauntlet or combat
trial if you will
in turn benno also seems to have a thing
for trains it seems
and refers to a spirit tracks inspired
dungeon one where you progress by
expanding the rail system inside the
dungeon to access new areas
something that would fit a steampunk
environment
breath of the wild introduced a rich and
complex chemistry engine and with it
came the power of electricity as well
and while we already saw electricity
being used to solve puzzles inside the
shrines and some of the divine beasts i
think the zelda team only scratched the
surface when it comes to the
possibilities
as such fallen saber would like to see
this idea turned into a full dungeon
concept
rather than some of the scattered micro
challenges and i
fully agree one of the most fun aspects
of this element was how flexible it was
and how it allowed you to cheat the
system a lot of times imagine
a giant power plant where as saber
suggests the main goal is to transfer
electricity from one place to another on
a large scale
an interconnected web which all works
together and influences the dungeon as a
whole
enemies could be defeated by using the
electricity to your advantage and set
traps for them
a bit like the plasmids from bioshock 1
and 2. the ultimate goal would be to
restore power to the main door leading
to the boss
which in fallen sabre's idea could be a
reintroduced version of the armos
knights from a link to the past
a central knight covered in an electric
barrier connected and surrounded by
smaller knights who need to be defeated
first in order to disperse the barrier
which also
kinda reminds me of baronade from
ocarina of time where you first had to
get rid of the electric jellyfish before
you could take on the brain
after all the smaller knights are
defeated link would then face off with
the central knight in a dark nut type of
duel combined with projectiles electric
beams and more craziness to deal with
feels strength oh space i love
space so do i mark thus a zelda dungeon
in space
yes please and chris pork jared whedon
acronym animations dan roland and camden
anderson
all feel the same way too i think a
dungeon in the form of a space station
would work
very well not only has it never been
done before in a zelda game thematically
but i'm also confident that the zelda
team can devise some excellent puzzles
think rooms with zero gravity
platforming and puzzle elements
a bit like the ones we found in dead
space we've already experienced walking
on walls and ceilings in twilight
princess
and as cool as that was it was a bit
sluggish at times now
imagine this but in zero gravity and
with breath of the wild's mobility
it would also be amazing to finally see
the planet where the series takes place
on in its full glory
maybe we'll be able to spot some secret
continents out there outside of hyrule
too
the highest we've ever been in the
franchises above the clouds in both
twilight princess and skyward sword and
i
am all in for taking it up even higher
to the edge of space
i mean it's not like the idea of
spaceships is completely foreign to the
zelda team either
as camden anderson points out we had the
aliens from majora's mask which almost
certainly came with the spaceship
we've also seen concept art from breath
of the wild involving an enormous mother
ship invading hyrule
so why not take us for a trip to the
stars for a unique dungeon experience
[Music]
malice it's one of the main themes in
breath of the wild and can be found in
almost every corner
of the map a remnant of calamity ganon's
attack on hyrule 100 years ago
and it seems that for the sequel we will
see this hate-filled substance return in
some shape or form
as seen from the e3 trailer farron says
that he would love to see a malice
themed dungeon
one where you have to get rid of the
malice as you advance from floor to
floor
and i think this could definitely work
we've already seen malice being used as
a way to obstruct ling's progression
like in hyrule castle or some of the
labyrinths we've also seen malice-based
enemies in age of calamity which could
make a comeback or completely new
enemies based on this concept
quinwood's idea is a bit different but
also pitches the idea of an item capable
of getting rid of malice which in a
dungeon like this
could work as a progression item at
first large parts of the dungeon could
be rendered inaccessible due to the
ganon goop
okay that just sounds wrong anyway
obtaining this item or ability would
fully open up the dungeon and you're
good to go
quinn also suggests a sort of malice
sludge monster as the final boss
one which obviously would have to be
defeated by utilizing your malice
cleaning tool slash ability
[Music]
now here's an idea that definitely
hasn't been done before in the zelda
series
a dungeon island kate fallon makes the
comparison to eventide island which was
already a fan favorite side quest so to
see something like this return but in a
bigger
more dungeon-like form would definitely
be amazing furthermore just like with
eventide you could either lose all of
your stuff
altogether and have to clear the dungeon
using only the items you can find on the
island or you lose all your stuff and
you have to go get them back one by one
by exploring the island
battling enemies and solving puzzles
we've seen sort of a similar scenario
in oracle of ages where link gets
stranded on an island and the natives
steal all of his equipment but here
getting them back was more or less a
glorified trading sequence
anonymous monkey adds an extra touch to
the idea of an island-based dungeon
turning it from one island
into a group of islands i.e an
archipelago instead
link would then be able to travel
between the different islands through
all sorts of different means
whether it's finding or constructing a
raft climbing to a high place and
paragliding to the next island or
perhaps some islands could be connected
by bridges the sea surrounding the
islands could potentially be
turbulent and dangerous due to a storm
preventing link from simply swimming
from one island to the next
am nox does his name justice and came up
with a hylian version of fort knox a
sort of secret vault perhaps tied to the
royal family where all sorts of secrets
are stored nox points out some of the
dlc items as an example
which are said to have been stolen from
within hyrule castle somewhere i really
like the idea of a dungeon tied to the
royal family
as it could give a different spin on the
dangers link has to overcome
a dungeon like this could for example
incorporate enemies and obstacles which
are not
inherently evil but are instead simply
part of the security systems of the
vault robotic guards laser traps and
other security measures link has to
either avoid or deactivate
think a bit like the guardians from
skyward sword found in the silent realm
sections
not evil or malicious but still
nerve-wracking once they start coming
for you
simon halen also weighs in on this idea
a dungeon primarily based on stealth and
evasion
also a bit like the yiga clan hideout
and the forsaken fortress
which i think fits perfectly with the
idea knox presented the goal of a
dungeon like this could be to retrieve
some sort of ancient artifact one which
the royal family had hidden away inside
their vaults and is necessary to advance
the main plot
who here likes clowns nobody right
clowns are creepy f
so what would be more awesome than
whacking a clown across the face with
the master sword
a creative name and i am again great
names guys
both came up with the idea of a carnival
or fun house type of dungeon
mario already had the privilege of
visiting a theme park twice
actually so now it's link's turn and not
just any carnival
a dark and creepy carnival preferably
one set during night time to get those
colorful lights shining bright
obviously again because i'm a silent
hill nerd one of the first things that
came to my mind was the lakeside
amusement park from silent hill for
zelda
probably not as dark and disturbing as
this one but
you know it goes without saying that
with a carnival type of dungeon you
could do
so many different things since well it's
a theme park haunted houses a ferris
wheel roller coasters all sorts of ways
to spice up the gameplay
and as im suggests a boss fight with a
giant jester or clown type of monster
perhaps even while riding a roller
coaster which immediately makes me think
of mario sunshine
you can never go wrong with pirates in
my book and andrew allred and silver
shadow seem to feel the same way now
this is not necessarily a new idea we
already had a pirate fortress in
majora's mask and of course the sand
chip in skyward sword but this is one
theme i wouldn't mind being revisited
again in a different form
especially since the pirate fortress in
majora's mask didn't really feel like a
pirate themed dungeon
at least not in the classical sense and
aside from the fight with the robot
pirate captain even the sand chip felt
more like a technology type of dungeon
where was the rum the sea shanties and
the treasures one idea i really like
would be an underwater dungeon perhaps a
sunken pirate ship or a pirate
stronghold at the bottom of the ocean
one which as silver shadow suggests
could be infested with undead stealthos
pirates you know what i'm talking about
like the first pirates of the caribbean
andrew and silver both have plenty of
ideas teams of treasure
whirlpools a boss captain who plays the
organ like davy jones you can go
all out with this pirates are awesome
thus another pirate-themed dungeon would
be
awesome too
[Music]
jump on everything greg amlin scifi and
master spongebad all came up with
a similar idea which i think would be
amazing
an ancient abandoned chica factory
laboratory we've seen plenty of
different guardian types in breath of
the wild but
where did they actually come from well
we know that the sheikah built them
but how i'd be hesitant to think that
they built them by hand right plus in
skyward sword we've seen that the shika
also had a factory type of facility with
conveyor belts and robots who were
mining time shift crystals
so what if there's a long forgotten
shika factory in hyrule perhaps
underground or inside a mountain or
something like that a place where the
guardians were made and where we could
see unseen prototypes which never got
finished in time
this way nintendo could introduce brand
new guardian types never before seen
an even more awesome addition to this
overall idea comes from jump on
everything who suggests a sort of mother
computer or central unit who controls
the entire facility and has gone haywire
which immediately makes me think of
glados from portal or the autopilot from
wally as the factory was abandoned the
central unit became self-aware and
continued to keep the facility
operational
as such this central computer nor the
guardians it controls are infested with
malice the mother computer
simply developed a mind of its own and
deems anyone trespassing or trying to
shut the lab down as a threat
to its existence this computer would
have complete control of the facility
and
eyes everywhere continuing to try to
attack link by sending guardians after
him
obstructing his path and so on as for
the aesthetics i really like the idea
from craig amlin
an architecture similar to that of the
sheikah shrine since it's based on the
same technology but overgrown with moss
vines and ivy giving it a sort of
post-apocalyptic feel a factory which
has been abandoned for 10 000 years
yet is still desperately kept up and
running by its central computer
now this one is a very creative idea
brought forth by david p
a color dungeon link's awakening had a
color dungeon but that was mostly based
on the fact that the game boy color
could finally display
well the color which was a big deal back
then
but aside from that this dungeon was
nothing special and mostly just an
excuse to showcase puzzles which can be
solved due to the fact that you can now
see the color of the switches tiles
levers etc what david suggests
is way more creative a dungeon that
starts out completely black and white
when you first enter
kinda like hyrule caso in the wind waker
but as you progress through the dungeon
you bring back its original palette
one color at a time so say you conquer
one part of the dungeon
all the parts that are red for example
are now visible because you can now see
that color this then allows you to solve
specific puzzles
for instance one door will only open if
you manage to match a grid with red
tiles which you would only be able to
solve if the color red
is visible as you progress more colors
are restored and hence you can solve
more and more puzzles
some which require two colors visible
three four and so on
remember when phantom ganon came in and
out of paintings in ocarina of time
well how about a dungeon based on this
concept which is something not a
friendly name came up with
something like a house or a weird
mansion filled with paintings which link
can enter
obviously for many this calls back to
mario 64. but unlike that game where
each painting is a whole world here it
would be on a smaller scale where each
painting functions as a single dungeon
room instead
and the aesthetics of these rooms can
depend on the art style of the painting
so one room can look like a black and
white sketch
and the other can have a watercolor look
to it and so on granting a wide variety
of aesthetics for this dungeon
and mechanically the options are endless
one painting could be
unfinished for example and you need to
somehow fill in the rest
some paintings may be hidden away in a
chest somewhere and link has to find it
and hang it on a wall somewhere so he
can enter it which is a nice and
different take on the lock and key
concept
instead of collecting keys you are
literally collecting new rooms to
explore
ever since the trailer for breath the
wild sequel speculation about the
possibility of a playable zelda has been
running rampant
and for good reason two-player co-op or
even switching between two different
characters for long periods of time has
never been done in the 3d zelda title as
such storwise boss 69
face pwnage wtf ivan anaya and
la beldam dumanur would all like to see
a dungeon where you can swap between
link
and zelda and label dumb makes a good
reference to a past game
some of you may remember seiken's
hideout from the andrew and cafe side
quest in majira's mask which as far as i
can remember was the first time that you
could take control of a character
other than link however brief it may be
later in the wind waker we also had
medley and macar which could also be
controlled on a room-to-room basis
but please god make switching between
characters less of an ordeal than it was
here
storewide boss envisions a boss fight
where link and zelda fight together with
each using their unique abilities to
fight
facepwnitch proposes a dueling peaks
dungeon where link and the other
character presumably zelda entered the
dungeon on opposite
sides of the peaks from here they both
have to overcome their own challenges
until one of them runs into a roadblock
then you switch to the other character
and clear their section and so on
until finally the two meet at the boss
room for the final challenge
ivan makes it even more interesting and
suggests that the dungeon could be split
into two different time periods and
either link or zelda is in the past
while the other is in the present
which would make for some mind-boggling
puzzles where one character changes
something that affects the other time
period
lastly we have legend zone and their
idea for a dungeon located on an
incredibly large creature
i.e leviathan of course in some ways the
divine beasts were already like this
but as big as they were i think that not
only can we go bigger but instead of a
mechanical beast it's an
actual living being like the titans from
xenoblade chronicles 2.
we have been on the backs of giant
organic creatures before
but never in a dungeon setting of course
this beast would have to be
pretty massive and could be moving
around hyrule either flying around or
maybe even swimming underwater
legend zone says that the beast could be
infested with a parasite one which link
needs to slowly chip away at by
destroying parts of it as you progress
until it's finally dead think the city
in the sky from twilight princess
crossed with the levias and bilocite
battle from skyward sword
and with that we have reached the end of
the list but before we close the
curtains i'd feel bad if i didn't at
least do some honorable mentions
i want to start by highlighting
sharpshooter zigbar dr pudus and patrick
aycock's ideas
these are all extremely long and
detailed they basically describe an
entire dungeon experience from beginning
to end
including the setting items specific
puzzles and even dialogue
they were too extensive to include here
since i would have had to oversimplify
them way too much
so instead i will make a community post
where you can read them in full detail
so if you're interested be sure to give
them a read as they are very creative
next we have patrick kuhn and their idea
for a fairy dungeon
lois joe jesco who came up with a
dungeon idea inside link's head so
basically a dream dungeon julia
sencina's doggo dungeon where you need
to save dogs from a demon cat
lemmy de cool a fire dungeon which is
frozen at first and is progressively
restored as you make your way through
luke wilson tv who suggested a dungeon
inside the belly of a big goron
ella west and their idea for a dungeon
companion who joined you and then at the
end
turns out to be evil and waterbear08 who
had a similar idea to luis
a mental dungeon inside link's own mind
and
that is all for now i just want to say
thank you to everyone who submitted
their idea whether it made it on the
list or not
it was a lot of fun reading them and i
got all sorts of inspiration from it and
of course a huge huge thanks to
ganondoodles for their amazing work
i will put any links to their social
media and other stuff in the description
and the pinned comment below so you can
check out even more artwork
these were just sketches so you can
imagine how good the real stuff is
and lastly thank you to anyone who
followed my content or supported the
channel in any way in the past year
and here's to many more years ahead of
us my voice is just
completely gone at this point so if you
guys don't mind i will do the patreon
and member shout outs next week
i'm gonna need some rest see you all
next time this is don
signing off and have a good one
my
[Applause]
[Applause]
from
you